Speaker 1: Let's go next to.
Let's go to Veronica. Hello.
Speaker 4: Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 4: Hi, Debbie. I just got one question
I wanted to ask you. Do you think that the
vaccination rate is accurate? Because I
know that the U.S. is vaccinating like
a lot of tourists and people from abroad.
And do you think that that affects like
a vaccination rate of the citizens here,
Speaker 1: Veronica, or are you from Argentina?
Speaker 3: No, I'm not. You
are. Where are you from?
Speaker 1: From anywhere from Ecuador. OK, yeah.
So OK, very good question. There are places now
like in Florida where tourists can
get vaccinated. And then there's
a real question as to whether they're being
reported as an American vaccination or not. So
you're completely right that the number is going
to be off slightly because of foreigners that are
getting vaccinated. But it's a relatively small
number, so I don't think it's off by very much.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I know they are being reported
as Americans up because my family has been here
and they got vaccinated and they didn't even
ask them like, right, are you from here?
OK, I got another question. Sure. I live in
Mississippi. OK. Wow, you know, this is a red
state. Yes. So I think that yesterday and Dr.
Jill Biden came here like for the vaccination
thing that Joe Biden was doing. Yeah. To
promote vaccination. And do you think that
that's the really has an effect? Because I think
the people here, if they haven't got their vaccine
already, they are not going to change their mind?
Speaker 1: I think that it's not going to move
the numbers significantly, but I think it will
make a little bit of a difference. Is it enough
to change our path to herd immunity? I don't
know, but I still think every little bit helps.
OK, thank you, baby Veronica,
where in Ecuador are you from?
And now Quito is quite elevated, right, is it
12000 feet? Yes, I think it is. Are you completely
used to the elevation if you go back
to visit or does it take you time to
adjust? And you said you are even
living in the lowlands of Mississippi,
your body still is ready for the elevation.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I went there like three months
ago and I was it was completely fine. Really?
Speaker 1: Yeah, OK. All right. Good news.
Speaker 2: Thank you, David.
Speaker 1: OK, thanks, Veronica.
Veronica from Ecuador. Great court. Unclear
what was happening in the background. I know,
but I found the call generally riveting,
so I thought I'd just let it slide